by the way you still uh close with Pete
Davidson I know you guys are uh yeah
that's my man that's your man I love
that dude you speak to him a lot you
know what Pete is really good about he's
really good about reaching out because
even like he'll change his number and
stuff like that so you know we're always
off doing our thing but he'll always
reach out and even when he's going
through stuff and you know we've kind of
been there oh yeah throughout the years
he's one of those that will tap in
regardless of what's going on you and
Pete that makes sense here friends I
mean you guys both I taught him
everything he knows [__] yeah but you
know how when I was at 92 3 you know
Euro station uh I I used to also host a
comedy night at Gotham in the city and
there was this kid that would call my
morning show every single like week
talking about yo I'm funnier than you
put me on and it became almost like a
bit and I told him I will come down to
the show my car you know can his comedy
show and he came down at 15 years old
and ripped it and from then I took him
on the road with me he we worked on all
my stand-up specials together he went I
took him around the world for the first
time got a uh his passport uh and then
put him in his first movie I directed
this movie called school dance he played
this character that didn't have one line
but his name was stink finger and he was
just oh that's funny he would walk
around with his stinky finger and put
other people's nose and then like people
didn't know who this kid was but finger
turned into Pete Davidson and both you
guys I just realized you both dated Kim
Kardashian what do you think of that did
you ever consider that Rumble young man
Rumble yeah I mean you guys ever get
together no you know what interestingly
enough and this is respect to to Pete
during that time that was probably our
most distant time you know because I was
on uh and then when you probably trying
to be you know I was doing my daily talk
show trying to be funny and you know and
he's like dealing with all of that
um and I remember it was a moment
because you know I was I'm also really
or at the time you know I was really you
know close with Kanye and that that was
a weird dichotomy because I always say
I'm the person who introduced Kim to
Kanye you were with Kim and then you
introduced Kim to Kanye I believe I mean
it was like 2006. this was a long you
know it was a long time and you were
cool with that or were you were
heartbroken but they was nah because I'm
saying like that's probably when they
first actually met each other they
probably didn't get together until years
later but I'm just saying like you know
it was one of those times
talk to Kanye all the time but um that
during that time
um you know I felt I felt for all of
them man I mean like they have to live
your life out in the public and people
passenger I've been there before Nick
listen to me I'm a radio guy your first
show on this new day weekend daily
Cannon radio show on AMP you got to do
you Kanye and Pete do a round table on
dating pin this will be big I have way
more respect for Kim like I think the
interview with just me and Kim would be
more more intriguing she's the one that
had us all wrapped around her finger
she's the one like if you if you want to
talk about who's the most fascinating
and that's the the billionaire woman
that's making all these men go crazy
good